you
[Music]
and now I would like speaking of great
people and kind people and nice people I
would like to introduce christos
papadimitriou I'm you know I'm really
really thrilled and honored that he
agreed to come and speak to us for this
event he's really a giant in computer
science and one of my heroes and he's
one he's won the canoe surprise he was
one that john von neumann medal he's won
the godel prize he's the fellow of the
ACM fellow of national academy of
engineering a member of National Academy
of Sciences an Academy American Academy
of Arts and Sciences he's also a
longtime friend and has served a lot at
dyemax he was on one of the original
boards for dyemax
and so I have this email from Christos
to Fred from 1997 giving his evaluation
of how well died Max is doing in
research he's written five textbooks
many many are technical articles on many
topics he co-founded my field
algorithmic game theory he introducing
the first worst case analysis of worst
case of equilibria and and the price of
Anarchy as a grad student he settled the
complexity of euclidean Traveling
Salesman problem and then much more
recently settled it for Nash equilibrium
and he has eight honorary doctorates in
addition to his PhD at Princeton he's
also a novelist he's written three
novels one of which is logic comics a
graphic novel I have a copy here it this
one's personally special to me I got a
copy when it first came out and my
daughter was my younger daughters kind
of interested in graphic novels so I
started reading it to her it's not
really it's not a kids book but if she
was eight at the time but so we're kind
of glossed over some of the more adult
type issues but it's really she found it
fascinating and I kept reading it for I
think that was probably a year or so
where like she wanted to read this every
night at night and and for some reason
she got really interested in the
barbershop paradox we I think I still
have a bookmark
that page we kept going back to the
barbershop paradox and rereading and
rereading it so this one is special to
me and I have a few copies so I Christos
has graciously agreed to sign some
copies so he'll sign mine for my
daughter so thank you and but he also
and a few of you have said they would
want a copy already but if anyone else
wants a copy a signed copy of logic
comics I have a few copies so let me
know
so with that I'll I would love to have
Christos come up and we can get started
on his talk on brain computation
excellent so thank you very much I'm
delighted to be here I I have been
involved to die max I mean no sir is not
you agree do people at all times of my
career in the nineties die max was the
game
I hope much to dynamics and of course I
have been we have a long history of
collaboration semester
thanks that's that's these are two
amazing groups to make sure great so I'm
glad to help one one question that is
probably in your mind is why would the
computer scientists work of the brain
okay you know and you're right I mean oh
so so and you're right I mean no
computer scientists work on other things
right I mean oh so and we did we did for
the longest time okay so so for the
first six decades of our field we worked
on the computer okay we were obsessed on
for the computer so we also you know we
were so obsessed to computer that we
made the mistake of naming or disability
so but so it's in retrospect it's it's
very strange that such a large group of
intelligent adults was
was so stuck up with a computer but we
were okay I was okay so you know we
thought it was amazing so even though we
did we understood computation like was
never understood before you know this
was six long years of incredible work
very creative work we solved we solve
problems that that it was very very you
know databases compilers you know that
it was a major major intellectual
engineering feat and then of course it
all and that you know because what
happened is that is that the internet
came okay and and we immediately
realized that that was the whole point
okay you know that the computer was the
gadget that brought us and this is what
this is what we were interested in and
of course you know so work when when
when when we when you focused on the
Internet's or even you are my mind
wandered okay because because I mean oh
it's easy when you are doing you know
you know basically you go from you know
it see it's an easy step to go you know
actually I don't think that many of you
realized how similar the universe is
with the internet okay you know so you
know it okay so they're the same thing
alright so and this is something that
that has been called the lens on the
sciences you know computational
algorithm aggression of the science or
computational other than pseudoscience
and by this I mean the following Sorvino
in simple terms that that occasionally
when there is you know in a challenging
problem is challenged several problem in
sciences of all kinds social biological
and so on and physical if the computer
scientists or you know looks at this
problem occasionally not not always not
even often okay but occasionally
unexpected progress happens okay and and
and and the three key is I mean know if
I can sort of you know simplified a lot
is to fantasize that this scientific
object be
the universe sell the market so you know
that evolution is trying to compute
something okay you know so and and then
use our insights of what it means to
compute things right you know so this is
this and this is that what I'm going to
this is a trick I'm going to play with
the brain and before that let me just
tell you a couple of things I mean oh
that's you know in game theory and
economics you know as you know you know
one of the one of the most important you
know you know in some sense or you know
the the birth of the new era of
economics you know you know it was was a
1950s when when John John ash approved
this famous theorems or you know that
not all games have a Nash equilibrium
and this this was in some sense the
start of modern economics part of the
part of the reason is that is that our
own the brave were inspired to prove
their theorems but not only that sort of
you know it was it was in some sense it
economists got got a license when the
thing about something to say let's see
what happens at equilibrium okay you
know and this and this is this was an
important methodological theoretical
tool okay so um and it turns out you
know that that that finding our
circulatory the intractable problem and
this in in to a large extent cancels
this you know in other words this life
license is temporarily revoked okay so
you know for computation original so
that's that's a nice that's a nice
compliment for computation alright so
and another another something else is is
that you know looking at evolution from
with this computational lens you know
you realize and expect the things for
example but the Volusia population of
genotypes is equivalent mathematical
equivalent to the genes of the of the of
the of the species playing a game
okay and the strategies the game are the
alleles of every gene and the
probability which they play the
strategies are the frequencies of the
alleles in the population play the
genetic pool of the population and it's
a repeated game because it is the
repetition of the generations of the
rules of the fish species and and the
amazing thing that is played through
multiplicative ways updates okay
adaboost okay so that and this is and
this is a I mean you know I remember I
remember my co-author and this who
mentions irani telling me you know once
once we realize that this is how
evolution works or you know this is a
useful mathematical reviewable origin he
told me you know crystals now I have
much more confidence in evolution so
another thing that you guys get out of
this or you know if you if you you know
just by applying convex programming
gravity you see something very
interesting that that every gene in
every generation what it optimizes is a
trade-off between cumulative Fitness and
a little entropy so in other words
diversity of the population genetic
diversity is one of the things that that
are being explicitly optimized you know
evolution okay so that these are all
things these are all insights that were
just a few equations away from from the
standard mathematics population genetic
mathematics but so we know it to
computer scientists or to the to gets to
get to get to them so frankly you know
so this is this is the question that I'm
either studying okay how does the my you
know how does behavior cognition
intelligence language okay how do these
things come from molecules cells
synapses wet stuff okay you know so and
and you know the way I see it you know
you know you know the way visualize this
question is like I call it the the
sunset from the brain for
from the Berkeley Hills question in the
following sense that every time I see
this and I had opportunity to see it
many times in the past you know what
comes to my mind is why isn't everybody
stop what they're doing okay you know
and come here the city's right so you
know so when you work on the brain
really so no you look at other people we
say wow strange they're working on other
stuff oh yes yeah so okay about five
years ago would sound of Impala we
decided to to seriously look at this
problem and that the first thing you do
is you you you you buy this book okay so
you know five summers ago we did you
know we did so that's called principles
of neuroscience it's called for debates
it's all the candles smart book okay so
you know so it's it's a beautiful
extensive compendium of what is known
about the brain and sorry no it's every
every four years it's been written and
as a result it becomes 200 page sticker
okay you know so anything about it
that's not right okay you know the title
is principles of neuroscience right I
mean oh so principles as time progresses
you destroy yourself
Samuel so when the Greeks decided to
find the principles of new geometry okay
you know they ended up with four lines
right um no condom hey so uh and and and
so I mean oh this you know there's
something wrong here you know is end and
my hero is Richard Axel now my colleague
in Columbia Columbia put this very you
know when I read this I said Wow
sort of you know I could not I could not
pray for something for something better
for my research program for axel to say
okay so he said the following in an
interview we did not have a logic logic
a logic for the transformation of neural
activity into hotel I viewed asserting
this logic as the most important feature
future generation you know saw Direction
research Direction neuroscience so I
mean oh this amazing this man who is who
is sort of you know the the the the Pope
of experimental neuroscientist right I
mean oh so he's telling us that that we
don't have so you know is he telling us
that what you need is a formal system
right so in order to and and so the
question is what kind of formal system
would fill this bill okay
and and that's what I'm you know I have
an idea okay you know that's what I'm
going to present okay so it is clear we
know that's this is what this is what
I'm after
good so let's start somewhere really
humble okay you know so this is this
about fruit flies okay and and they have
they have an apparatus they have already
have a nose okay so you know and they
have a way of remembering smells and
it's the following I mean oh there are
there are 50 kinds of others okay so and
and there are there are receptors that
that that neurons that actually sends
these orders and eventually their
projects that to these neurons feed us
50 neurons and then something very
interesting happens I mean old something
that computer scientist immediately saw
you should sit up on their chairs right
let me know there is a projection from
50 dimensional space to 2002 the
dimensional space in a random projection
randomly projected to much higher
dimension four times higher and then
another very interesting thing happens
okay very computer science II to that
there is a very sir there is a
inhibitory neuron here which once
excited by this by this havoc that
happens here it it very immediately
intervenes and comes them down and out
of these two thousand neurons only the
fifty I believe at the hundred sorry the
hundred highest one survived in the rest
you know in other words becomes a zero
one okay so you know it becomes a zero
in vector and and only the top hundred
are chosen and everything else is goes
back to zero so
so this is the this is the process and
it's really worth you know it's you know
in some sense it is it is the base of
what I'm going to tell you okay we call
this random projection followed by cap
our PNC 100 winners out of 2000 okay so
that's okay ah okay interesting question
how do we know that this is a random
bipartite graph okay and you're not
going to believe this okay
but-but-but-but six years ago this man
axel did it okay
created this bipartite graph so this is
this degeneracy matrix okay and and the
bottom line is sorry no the past it flew
through all kinds of statistical tests
and it is a random bipartite graph okay
so you know with biases in the degrees
all right I mean other than that it's
it's it's it's it's a random bipartite
graph and in fact it is in the left
nostril of of the of the of the of you
know it's the left-right are different
different species have different and so
so I mean oh it's sort of amazing that
random is so important that this critter
probably has it's the DNA a random
random number generator okay so you know
so this is you know it's it's it's it's
mind boggling I'm you know so and
randomness of course is the base of what
I'm going to tell you and by a random
projection and cap I mean the following
that you have that you have a Bernoulli
shower okay so you know where you get
you get something that looks like this
and then out of this and you know you
take the highest K okay and that's and
that and this and everything else this
becomes one where everything else
becomes you know that's okay good so one
amazing thing that was that was you know
does good you know Sanjoy Dasgupta and a
couple of us and his cohorts from from
San Diego
they wrote a very interesting paper
three years ago that basically they
proved essentially that that
it preserves a similarity right I know
that but what I'm saying is that if you
have a to similar smells okay well
measure of similarities their
intersection then the output will be two
for other similar smells okay equally
similar okay so and that's sort of
that's it that's an image from
generation it was an empirical
observation in their paper and in fact
they noticed that it has it has better
property better recall properties then
sort of done the very clever
sophisticated algorithm came out of
Stanford MIT of sort of locality
preserving hashing okay so well and this
was this was a very interesting surprise
and in fact very zen the underlying
mathematical reason okay that that the
intersection of all these sort of you
know in other words if alpha is the is
the degree of intersection the
percentage of intersection of the two
smells okay the percent of the
intersection of the two of the two sets
of neurons that that is going to record
them is is this okay and this looks like
a very nonlinear function except that
for the for the values of N and K for
the fly it turns out that this very
linear okay okay and and and in fact we
suspect that this is not necessary you
know that this is the right the right
answer no in fact empirically if this is
the 45 degree that says that it's
exactly preserved this is what the
sliders okay so it's very very very
close but enough of the fly right I mean
oh let's let's do something else
so you know the question is that some
single model was happening mammals so I
mean also it turns out that it does and
there is no evolutionary connection sort
of you know that there were two
independent discoveries are very similar
very similar mechanisms except that in
the mammals there is there is a catch
and this cat is sort of the beginning of
my story okay you know so so it turns
out that that again mammals have you
know further for example the mouse this
is the head of a mouse it
fifteen K 1,500 kind of smells okay we
have 500 smells okay we lost a thousand
okay because don't need them okay so but
but the Mamas have fifteen fifty
thousand smell 1,500 smells different
different utterance that they can be and
they have different 15,000 different
different cells that are all factory
receptors right I mean oh and and
they're all in the roaster you know in
our nostrils we have we have we have
billions of cells okay and each one of
these cells specializes in one of a 500
500 smells all right I mean oh so and
then if we smell something these goals
you know this project these neurons
projects or actions to a place here is
all you know it's like a pea-sized part
of the cortex called the olfactory bulb
okay the factory bulb has is is divided
into glomeruli and so for example
ammonia sort of you know is is
projecting to one glomerulus so and and
and and then the interesting stuff
happens okay and this is something that
again axial in a paper he of his in in
2011 and that was always an inspiration
for us I mean Oh described and basically
what happens is that these projects to
this ancient form of cortex called the
telephone cortex in other words where
the the neurons here their axons go here
many other places but most significantly
here right amino and they're they create
a permanent smell which a permanent
memory which then it's transferred
elsewhere and and go throughout okay but
but let's let's look at this particular
mechanism how it is done okay and and
here is how this is described in the in
the discussion section of that later
another that may cause a small subset of
beautiful cortex neurons to fire
inhibition triggered by the sympathy of
this activity that's exactly what
happens in the in the
in the in the fly will prevent further
firing so it's going to be sort of you
know a particular set of near that fire
but then now comes the interesting part
as this small fraction of cells will
then generate sufficient recurrent
excitation to recruit a larger
population Munoz here's the secret
mammals in in flies you know these two
thousand cells they were no there were
no axons going the worldö connections
between them there are synapses between
them
here there are recurrent synapses okay
and so the thing will not stabilize
alright I mean oh these small fraction
cells they're going to recruit more okay
because now there is a very simple
synaptic input from these new things
right and this will be so it will move
and then move again and move again in
the extreme some cells would receive an
Africa and people to fire without
receiving initially input ok so so if
there's something very interesting is
happening here so let me let me you know
imagine that you have a set of spike in
neurons all right I mean oh that's I
think that this is you know so this is
Megan is very that I propose is very
general okay I mean oh that's this is
something that mammals do okay that we
do alright and that's the following that
if we have a memory of this a set of
spiking neurons okay and this neuron
spike in some area okay over brain and
this is a different area such that there
is a bipartite graph over recurrency
neck actually the random bipartite graph
okay random is very important what I'm
going to tell you and then a random no
bipartite graph okay between the
recurrent graph between in this area
what will happen is that in the
beginning as in the fly something will
come up okay bye-bye precisely by a
random projection and cut but then these
will start firing okay also and now the
whole this whole area is going to
receive both input from here any buffer
there and as a result there going to be
a new set of winners right I mean oh and
there will be this and now these two are
going to fire this is going to be
forgotten and lost these two are going
to fire and as a result a third one
we'll come okay and and so on okay so
the curve and the crucial question is
will it converge so is there something
that is there a stable member going to
be formed and it turns out that that and
also does it does it reverse a
similarity before telling you the
results are just a little suspense let
me tell you that I mean oh maybe this is
one of the most interesting parts of
what we are doing we have a model of the
brain okay sort of ambitious and silly
as it sounds right I mean oh so you
imagine you'd have a finite number of
brain regions each contains and neurons
inhibition means that in each one of
these regions only k out of n and think
of K as square root of n fire okay some
pairs of areas are connected by directed
BNP graphs okay bipartite random graphs
and all of them are connected
recurrently by directed GMP okay and
that's the model
okay nothing else all right I mean
though the question is what computation
can be done with this model okay that's
that's damask and and and suppose that
neurons firing the skillet steps which
is amino the influence of dyemax
immediately right I mean oh so it's you
know it's not true it's you know it's
one of these assumptions that it's both
is both extremely useful and productive
and also indefensible okay you know so
you know but they don't fire you know
but but suppose they do they are
selected by random projection and cut
and the cap we assume that this area
these these arrows can be enabled and
disabled okay that that there is some
control somewhere that this and then you
have plasticity that's another that's
the new
that's the new element of what I'm going
to tell you if a from neuron I to neuron
J either the same area or in downstream
area I fires and in the next step J
fires
the way to Phi J is multiplied by by
something okay I mean oh it become it
gets increased and then you have from
your status forgetting and so on but I
mean oh these are don't interfere with
our room but um you know this is the
model of our model of the brain and
incidentally when I say a model of the
brain a lot of people have been sort of
have mathematical models of the brain um
you know I'll tell you where our
emphasis is is is a is importantly I
think and enable it way different people
have been interested in modeling the
sensory cortex okay the visual cortex
the auditory cortex and so on I mean oh
they do why because this this is what is
accessible to experiments right I mean
oh you wire an animal you use you show
it things you make it you make it make
some decisions sort of you know lick
some sugar okay so Romanian you have a
paper right I mean oh so this is this is
this is this is this is this is the this
is that Rodino for the past poor step
for from the past 50 years okay so you
know since urbanism this is the brand
butter so no of all neuroscience okay so
I am more interested first of all in the
human brain and I'm more interested in
something that is you know it only has
an old-fashioned term you know because
it's not it's not it's not a beloved
subject of anybody it's called the
association cortex okay it means
anything that is beyond sensors okay if
you wish it started it starts from the
hippocampus and later in other words
that's the inner life of our brain okay
so you know if I'm interested in
thinking about language storytelling
reasoning planning and so on this is
what I'm interested in
okay so that's and and it's it's it's
pitifully
little study again so the parameter side
we know suppose that every new every
every one of this area has about 10
million excitatory neurons but that the
Hobbesian brings it to have to to the
square root of that imagine that the
probability of
action is about 1,000 and and they
increased because of plasticity is 1.1
okay so this this this is the ballpark
figures that I'm interested in sorry I
there's no geometry there's no meter so
it's it's it's yeah but of course I mean
oh I'm thinking of it as as yes it's a
graph so there are three ideas
randomness selection but what I call the
random projection a cup and plus this -
okay these are the three the three
forces all right I mean that I'm
interested in okay and and and
everything I'll tell you so the theorem
is the following the probably the
process the process that I showed you
does converge exponentially fast with
high probability and the total number of
cells involved which is a measure of how
slowly to converge is if beta is bigger
than beta star which is which is this
this value so it's about point 0.15 then
it's it converges very fast otherwise
it's still converges as long as beta is
beta is not zero okay so plasticity
turns out and everything about it is not
it's not it's not surprising plasticity
helps convergence right amino that
because trans plasticity stability okay
if these things have been firing then we
help them a little more and therefore
they're going to keep firing okay and
they're going to be stable good and here
are our simulations and so on okay so
the result of such projection let's call
it an assembly it's not my a set of K
neurons in a brain area who's firing in
a pattern it's tantamount to our
thinking of a particular memory concept
name word episode etc okay so it's not
my idea okay this is in other words
that's no new nothing new right I mean
Oh everybody believes that I mean so you
know I know the extent to which they
think it's the key to how the brain
works difference but everybody believes
that roughly this is what's happening
okay
he'll propose the 70 years ago now you
know it has been they have been changed
by people who who were interested in
them then these you know boo said he was
of course at random at etre Albert at
Rutgers when he discovered this amino
they discovered the Soudan okay and and
and there are there are there are many
now they are sort of you know there they
are you know basically what we do that
is novel is we use them in a way that
Sauron had not been anticipated has not
had not been sort of systematically
worked out before and and we have
another Rivera we know our group with
group in in in Austria sort of you know
we have simulations that really in a not
in our model which is very schematic but
sort of in a very biologically accurate
model you know we know that they exist
and and by the way you remember the
concept of a gallon mother said okay
basically a self you know the neuron
that encodes your grandmother see much
right I don't know how many of you heard
of it I mean oh it used to be like
folklore neuroscience folklore I mean I
have a grandmother cell actually this if
you think about it this cannot happen
because if your say your grandmother
goes a cell there would be no
grandmother right let me know because a
cell cannot do anything right I mean
myself has no power
I mean oh only only big gangs of cells
have power okay we know so really it's a
grandmother assembly right I mean Oh
nowadays it's it's not called gramma
it's called Jennifer Aniston cell okay
you know or concept cells so because in
the 90s they caught somebody who whose
cell was firing only would when he saw a
picture of Jennifer Aniston or even
heard the voice of January cars and so
on okay so incidentally by the way after
my talk you have not only a Jennifer
Aniston cells but you're going to have
Jennifer Aniston cell cells
think about but don't go that way okay
okay so let's let's go back to let's go
back to to oh you know I mean the
business of trying to understand
computation in the brain the question is
what is the right level okay
molecules of course computation habits
at a molecular level
spiking neurons and synapses yes
definitely okay and people have been
pursue pursuing these two levels for
forever people will tell you that the
real computation happens in the
dendrites okay in other words were they
were the axons meet to the presynaptic
actions meet the postsynaptic neuron
that's where the computation happens
because they have many meeting points
and God knows how how the whole effect
is calculated right is it that if you
multiplicative marks or what sort of you
know it's it's a whole it's a whole
computation tree and yes I mean a lot of
computation happens then writes as well
okay and then there is whole whole brain
computation I mean that that's that's
very useful in cognitive science where
basically they do some experiments and
and then they say you see so the
subjects brain is a bit as if it exactly
that this program right I mean oh so
that's this is this is a these are all
useful but the question is there is
something in between that is missing
right I mean oh and let's let's remember
let's remember again what what the man
said right I mean know that we need a
logic I mean I think that the logic that
axle is looking for it lives there okay
and and so here is here is my bet okay
so you know here here is what what what
were thinking that we call the assembly
hypothesis but there is in the
intermediate level of brain computation
it's implicating carry the higher
cognitive functions of humans such as
the reasoning I mean oh it's also
important for animals but let me know
but but it will be sort of you know a
waste of our time to focus on our own
non-human animals right amino reasoning
planning language storytelling math
music okay so you know science okay it's
it's it's it's it's implicated in
the good things assembly said it's
basically sent a shoots main data
structure it means data type okay and
and the question is what are the
fundamental operations let me know we
have to come up with fundamental
operations the basic operations and by
the way tell me no it's not like should
not be an idle exercise sort of you know
saying well let's see perhaps assembly
so you know have a decent deal
boolean fine it should be average must
be useful and plausible when I say
useful it means that it should explain
an experiment otherwise sort of you know
why habit and plausible means that you
have to convince yourself that that
eventually it can be implemented by
neurons and synapses okay because
otherwise it's not it's not something
that you should should venture it okay
all right
so so one operation is is projection
right and I told you what it is is that
you have you have an assembly than area
and it can be projected it can create a
copy in a secondary okay it's a little
like an assignment in programming
languages except that when you say X
gets Y x and y I'm going to live
independent lives but these two
assemblies are forever tied together
okay and and this can always fire this
so he took on so the next time it will
fire this will fire as well okay if this
is enabled okay that's this is the idea
all right
so other operations it turns out that to
establish massive associated by sharing
cells okay so in other words you have
two assemblies in the same area and
there may be sharing cells why always do
they share cells okay everything has
square root of n they should share in
cells even a random it turns out the
share cells because there is an affinity
I mean oh I want to show you an
experiment that that okay so that's
these two assemblies fire and as a
result this was samples get together
okay this was a copy or as a projection
of this these are the projection of this
these two fire together this means that
they call card okay they have some Afeni
and as a result these these these and so
here is here is her here is amazing
experiment okay this one that was also i
opening for us
they they they recorded from one neuron
in one brain in one subjects brain and
that neuron turns out that it was like
the like the Eiffel Tower in here and
every every time the so that for tower
this fired okay actually they recorded
from a couple of dozens of patients and
from several hundred neurons but let's
focus on this one you're on right so
they show it other interesting things
that familiar things nothing okay I felt
our always okay then they show him
people famous people used to be the
president of the you remember that very
okay good so nothing okay let it do
something clever the Photoshop Obama in
front of the Eiffel Tower okay yeah so I
mean oh they probably did it in a better
way than I did okay and of course the
the neuron sister of the the Eiffel
Tower of course the fires right then
they swallow towers of course it fires
this other stuff nothing what the you
know fired
okay get it so these patients learned
that Obama has been to the Eiffel Tower
okay so in America and you discover this
experimental okay this is you know
amazing okay
and it's you know and the only plausible
explanation is the previous picture
right let me know that the Obama and and
and and you know that this neuron was in
job in the in rifle assembly but not in
the Obama said okay and because the
Obama and I shall call card it jumped to
the I fell to the Obama assembly right I
mean oh so now now it's both in the
Eiffel Tower and Obama okay the the
intersection interest and let me know
the then the sex increases become
something like 10 percent from 0 where
it should be and Association presented
the projection yes so associations
protected it all so once these are
associated now if they're projected to
differ an area it's still they're still
going to be associated okay it this one
happens in in the you know it's you know
it happens as I showed you I think okay
that and we showed you know control by
math but if you have two sets of neurons
the two sets of in the two sets of nodes
in the graph so you know Reina random
graph and they fire together then their
projections will come closer okay I know
this these are all things that you can
prove all right now so that's good so
here is another operation marriage okay
it's more complicated
basically assemblies X&Y from different
areas project to create one assembly
area a call it Z in another area call it
this call this I said new assembly Z and
this it has it has this new assembly has
ample Z has ample synaptic connectivity
to and from X&Y okay in other words what
you do is yet that you have built a tree
whose leaves are x and y and z is an
internal node of the tree
so it's useful for played for
hierarchies it's useful for language
okay so you know I see and and so this
is what happens okay that that these
fire yeah that these these are the
parents of this rule this fire and then
you can you create the two-way
dependencies between these three nodes
okay and and so the very interesting
thing is that this is the by far the
most sophisticated one operation who
have you have a couple more but it
requires the careful synchronization of
five brain areas and very strong
synaptic connectivity and plasticity
between between these two these three
areas and and one question I have
serving I'll come back to that I mean Oh
does it mean enhanced hardware okay so
you know in other words there is you
know I believe that this is something
that probably happens in the animal
brain also okay but I believe that that
that humans are a special equipped to
use it a lot okay so you know to use it
like many hundred times every second ok
and and the question is do you need
special hardware ok and and this is is
is a huge fiber that that that connects
that connects to brain areas that are
put that are important for language
Virna Kazarian Broca's area it's much
huger in humans than innate and here's a
surprise the left version is much bigger
than the right there okay and that's the
only anatomic asymmetry that you have
seen in the mammalian brain okay so
something's happening here okay but you
don't know what it is okay so good so
the assembly operations are are these
okay so there are some there are some
control operations which we need okay
but are complete means that if - or if -
if two assemblies are associated and one
fires there is a good chance that the
other one will fire okay so you know if
you if you if you remember a mob Obama
then then then you may you may remember
the Eiffel Tower next okay okay good
and the question is how powerful is the
system and other assumption it can
perform arbitrary square root of n
computation space computation okay so
it's very powerful
all right let me know anything and it's
n is a million sorry no that's that's a
lot of computation
all right all right cool okay how much
time good
ok cool ok excellent
ok that's where I'm going
ok the language right Amina so when I
tell my neuroscience friends I mean Oh
including accent that but that Amita
said in language I mean oh so basically
what what what they tell me is why so
you know that's the that's the hardest
thing that any brain has done okay why
don't you wait until we figure the brain
out and then we'll sit back light a
cigar and think about language ok no
that should be the last chair in the
cake and I don't think so ok you know I
think that language is an immense
opportunity because I mean our brain
sort of you know reflects the
environment but this an environment was
created by us ok we have not evolved
since language ok and and it's a last
meal as being adaptogen it evolved and
language has evolved right I mean has
evolved tremendously and extremely
rapidly ok think about this ok that
imagine a little girl in Japan and a
little girl in England okay
they speak very different languages ok
this language is evolved over four
thousand mothers grandmothers and so on
ok
mm mother mother's ago they were
speaking the same with the same language
okay so I mean oh the so Japanese and
English okay differ their difference was
mediated by 4,000 mother's okay and
that's the remarkable okay I mean this
this says that language has has adapted
a lot okay you know and it has adapted
to what I think I'd up to to our brain
okay languages are our suppose you know
are supposed to be easily teachable my
mother's two babies okay and and it's I
believe that it's an available as for
study the brain I mean in fact there is
there's an incredible number of recent
experiments I mean so let me let me show
you another experiment that's David pop
purple in NYU okay so you're wonderful
you know cognitive scientist universe on
experimental New Scientist so here is
his experiment he read the sort of in in
a very neutral voice sort of you know a
at four Hertz so you know forth for a
second that's this is this is precisely
the frequency which I'm speaking now
okay so you know it's it's amazing you
know everyone in the world everybody
speaks at four Hertz okay it's you know
people think that that that syllable is
not a linguistic concept but but about a
brain concept then your significance you
know so so it's so what happens is that
so they they they they read this
nonsense sequence of words okay and what
happens then then they record from
everywhere in by many technologies
different technologies what you get you
take the free the free analysis you get
a peak at 4 Hertz okay because four
times a second your brain has to say
what on earth does this mean okay you
know so and and and and and there is
activity for this for this for this and
and it's recorded so no surprises here
then it then pop or do something color
clever item you know so he repeat the
experiment except that every four words
that make sense okay okay
and guess what all right so of course
you have to every four four times a
second you have to recognize a word but
one time-saving second enough to say hey
a sentence okay and in the West that's
apparently different part of the brain
and twice every second you say a phrase
okay because basically what I think
happens is this right that's to me a
parsimonious explanation of this
experiment I mean I remember so you know
having having lunch with Chris man in
two years ago and and at sample if I was
or you know I was you know I was
overcome by temptation and turned to him
and looking him in the eye I told him
for the love of God
Chris do we have trees in our brain okay
and he came up back immediately
of course you do okay so you know in
Chris Manning is sort of you know a
mother among the computational linguist
the one who would be least inclined to
say that I mean oh so I think we have
trees in our brain you know the bubble
experiment came came later okay so so
here is another another experiment very
red to to to subject things like the
ball is he hit the truck in the truck
hit the ball different areas of this the
of the superior temporal gyrus responded
to track in the two sentences okay so
there is a special there is a special
area for for object is a special area
for subject and I'm sure a special area
for her okay and not only that but the
first area also responded the track was
hit by the ball so in other words what
what our brain does not have an area for
object but has an area for deep object
okay in other words it says here
forget the passive the stupid passive
voice maneuver okay the truck is the
object here not the subject so you know
this is some of the achons keys do not
like okay but but but but it's there and
another one so you know they come
deletion of phrases and especially of
sentences lights are parts of Broca's
area you know so here is Veronica's area
here is Broca's area this and this is
there quite a vesicular okay this is the
this is the huge bundle of nerves that
at all before and it joins the two you
want to hear something amazing this
bundle of nerves this this this big big
big fiber it becomes myelinated which
means becomes ready for use at the
twentieth month of the baby's life
exactly when sentences are beginning to
form
okay these are sort of amazingly data
okay so these are incredibly so you know
it's very tempting to do ridiculous
speculation okay so here is one way that
you know ammeter setting in half centers
you know I think parsing is an
interesting problem but it's really
reversible engineering of generation
generations the interesting problem the
real problem in in in in in in languages
when you see this what do you do okay
how do how do you record this as a fact
okay and basically what you do is you
you probably look for the verb first and
once you find it you project it to very
decays area then you find maybe there
may be the subject that you projected
then you find the maybe the the object
you project it and then you create
emerge between kickin ball and you call
this verb phrase and then you could
create a sentence which is boychiks ball
so what I'm saying is that there is a
wild speculation you can make about how
this is done using assemblies and and
and that agrees with with with
everything with the experimental data
that we have about about language in the
brain okay so ultimately I don't know
how many of you know the other story but
but the people who discovered you know
the
founders of neuroscience were an italian
spanish scientist called Camillo Golgi
and Santiago harmonica hull they both
sought at the same time the neuron okay
so using a technology that golde golde
had created and and then they disagree
they departed company at the time okay
because because basically Golgi said
okay what I see here is a network okay
this is is called a ridiculous right let
me know that network theory that the
brain is a network okay okay there are
some some density dense masses here
about who cares I mean other day
obviously the brain is a network and and
and we have to study the network whereas
Golgi said whereas Camila Monica Hal
said this is the neuron folks and you
should spend the next eight hundred
years studying the neuron okay and and
amino they completely disagreed and they
had they had they had a epic fight at
the Nobel Prize ceremony okay but but I
mean other question is who was right
okay and for of course it's obvious now
that they were both right okay and they
were both wrong to reject so vehemently
dope that the opposing view but in
another year more real way now Monica
Hal was right okay because there were no
scientists in 1900 ready to study the
network about there were a lot of
physicians who wanted to study in Iran
okay and and therefore that was okay so
no but that's the point of view that one
okay so i guess assembly hypothesis says
wait a minute maybe there is something
in between what when you focus there
will get new insights about this thing
okay so you know maybe there are sets of
neurons assemblies of neurons that can
explain a few things that could not be
explained before okay the side of a
brain is fascinating a bottomless
assembly center of operations may be one
productive path to thinking about
computation in the brain how did they
see the boxes logic okay so we don't
know how a simple is learning predict
okay and this you know unless unless you
nail that sort of you know it's the
theories incomplete
and how can one test verified falsified
assembly hypothesis to experiment so we
have with no we have a NSF grant that
was just approved that to work with
cognitive scientists in your assignment
is to try to see these things okay you
know and and you know frankly my my my
point of view is that fear is like that
they never there never falsified right
um you know you know they just they just
die in absence of supporting evidence
right I mean oh so so that's you know
and and and you know for all I know
that's that's what's going to happen
okay so these are the people who work
with Lhari about is the leader of the
fury group and you know science at
Columbia
Santos vampire is we started together
this trip to five years ago this is our
student dumb Interpol ski my colleague
my linguist Mike Collins at Columbia and
and Wolfgang masse who also started me
on this path he is a computer scientist
theoretical meter scientists who 20
years 25 years ago decided to become a
neuroscientist and became one of the
earliest converts okay so you know did
did what I'm doing 20 years earlier okay
so that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
no I disagree yeah let's all by language
I mean something something very specific
okay you know and and and chimpanzees
have cry have warning cries and so on
right amia language is something is
something that is you know I mean
grammar recursion unbounded number of
possibilities
oh absolutely I mean that's and that's
that's important I mean no language
probably exists amino comic languages
communication is only maybe eighty
thousand years old people believe that
language maybe existed half a million
years ago but I mean no but I mean if
you think about it we spend much more
time talking to ourselves that to
anybody else right I mean oh so so for
for half a million years maybe we were
talking to ourselves only okay but that
has a lot of advantages because sort of
you know it helps you a lot of
evolutionary bandage them you know it
helps you plan better understand make
make make more more complete models of
the world so you know and therefore you
could spread if you have it okay and
eventually the pressure is such that
because you have so much to say that
sort of you know that every little
mutation in your facial muscles and and
then chords so you know and actually
speech is not apparently very difficult
okay I'm you know there are a lot of a
lot of non prime know primate non-human
primate researchers who believe that
that so that many many monkeys already
yeah yeah yeah so so right right right
yes I mean also the question is yes and
that's why so no that's why you know
this is the reluctance of you know
because with humans you can only do very
very limited spare immense to do as
experiments like the Obama and Eiffel
Tower experiment you need to find people
in down-on-their-luck sort of you know
to sort of intractable you know and
that's sort of you know that's rare and
so these these these are rare that are
very very valuable that but but sort of
you know everything else is is much more
difficult and needs a lot of data
science to analyze the results you know
the other is are the other experimental
show you are essentially fMRI and EEG
experiments okay
and you really need them you know they
are not as crisp as a coke experiments
you know so you really need a lot of a
lot of analysis conclusions let's have a
couple more questions and the don't and
then we're gonna have a series of
lightning talks any more questions
good
operation oh I see
I have thought of that so we know it
will be interesting what we know how
much of our Lego language make any sub
duplicating in the in our artifacts okay
so you know that's that's that's
important I think about okay I have a
question that you had one slide about
the like the first time you create a
memory that it's recorded our hypothesis
that there's a random number generator
at that time to create the random
projection how how the further how the
first thing okay they are about this we
know a lot okay you know the first thing
happens in the in the hippocampus okay
so we know and we know that every second
of our lives or you know a new memories
and most of them of course don't survive
but some of them are projected further
and then they start having a life over
the road okay so you know that and so
how the first and how these memories are
created they are created from the
highest order for the highest levels of
sensory okay so you know for example for
you know whole object memories so you
know from from from the very base job
for the visual cortex our happiness so
you know are formed in an area called IT
in Ferro temporal cortex which is sort
of the highest the root of the of the
tree that is vision okay so you know and
these always project to the hippocampus
you know and this seems to be the
Gateway okay so know that true you know
if if the brain is a tree where they has
input and output this is a
if if we lose it I mean there is a
patient HM so even if a bustiers case
lost it sort of you know at some point
when people didn't know what to
accomplish was and surgeons would cut it
you know that did not create any memory
okay so you know believe it lived a
happy life for 15 years already know and
every time you know he saw his doctor
twice a week and every time he would
introduce but learn to play piano you
know so from you know is there some
things that we don't understand okay
yeah so yeah yeah yeah of course of
course of course actually got a
mechanism and uses it to bring yeah yeah
so so I mean no that's that's that's
that's amazing question you know and of
course I told you that that that Axl's
team did was able to measure this in the
play okay so and seems to be pretty
random okay for you know in in mammalian
brain you know that we know that there
are several deviations from Union for
our donors
okay for example if you know you have
two two neurons okay the the chance that
they are connected let's say is one in a
thousand if they are connected the
chance of is the reciprocal action
exists is like 100 okay so it is or or
you can have triangle completion if
these two this two exist then this is
very likely to exist so and these have
been studied and there are reasons to
believe that they are architectural
importance or you know to to enhance
algorithms
to make algorithm run more more robust
okay so so it's a it's a big question
the origin of this is geometry is it is
it plasticity I mean oh why why why do
this do this these biases so deviations
from beginning for Adam has happened
okay it's always a matter of matter of
matter of conjecture but I mean oh I
feel that that's a very important
okay great thank you so much Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]